and it's a girl Daisy and there's the
birthday girl geez good morning
Maryville it's a cold start to the day
right now only 21 degrees Audrey was one
of my only true friends she was always a
happy kid funk yet Daisy she was such a
daddy's girl in a small town everybody
is connected a lot of these families
have been here for generations
this guy started texting me it was kind
of like Oh older boys want to hang out
with us I think I was strong the boys
were pretty persistent then I guess
things got worse she was laying in the
yard and her hair was frozen to the
ground a group of boys crowded around
looking at a phone you carried her
upstairs passed out why did you lie to
the police
she said I'm scared I did something that
I didn't want to do who took the video
the whole town split up and decide Daisy
against people that were very very
vicious we started having issues with
vandalism it was picked up in the world
of social media that's when this erupted
into a firestorm to grandson of a
Missouri official has walked free we had
our house burned down these are very
hard cases no nice way to say that their
lives the verdict is hard to believe she
said I can't do this anymore
became more important to shield the boys
than it did to bring justice for the
girls try this tree
girls have as much culpability in this
world as boys do no one's gonna talk
about it then I will
it's sad but after that would sense
something clicked I can't ignore an army
and voices the words of our enemies
aren't as awful as the silence of
reference
okay bye